with Qiskit and actually teleport a quantum state on a quantum computer.
We'll start with three cubits, one each for the data cubit Q and the cubits A and B that will make up the E bit. We
start by creating the E bit. We apply a hatamard on cubit A followed by a C knot
between A and B to create the entangled state we're after.
Then we prepare Alice's cubit Q in a random quantum state by applying a random unitary shown by this box labeled
U. Then comes the teleportation. First the C knot between cubits Q and A. Then the hat had on
cubit Q. Then the measurements partially collapse the state so that only Bob's cubit B is in a superp position.
This is the point at which Alice would call Bob up and tell him what she measured. Then Bob would apply some
gates depending on those measurements. These red outlined boxes signify conditional gates. The first one means
that Bob applies an X gate to his cubit if cubit A is measured to be one. And
the second means he'll apply a Zgate also if cubit Q is measured to be one.
So now Bob should have a cubit in the same state that Alice's cubit was in at this point here after the unitary gate.
If all went according to plan, then we have teleported the quantum state. But how do we check that? We can run the
same circuit but make one small change.
Here we've added another unitary at the very end of the circuit applied to Bob's cubit. This unitary is the inverse of
the one we applied at the beginning to Alice's cubit. The reasoning here is that if this first gate created the
quantum state that is now teleported to Bob's cubit, then this one should undo it, taking Bob's cubit back to the zero
state. But of course, this undoes all of our hard work of teleporting the state in the first place. So we wouldn't want
to do this if we actually wanted to do something with the teleported state and if it were truly in an unknown quantum
state, we wouldn't be able to apply a unitary to undo it. Anyway, this is purely for diagnostic purposes to make
sure that teleportation was successful. If we measure Bob's cubit to be in the zero state, then we can be reasonably
sure that teleportation worked. Once we're sure that our protocol is working as expected, then we could remove this
final unitary and actually do something with the teleported state. But for now, let's just make sure it works. Let's
execute the circuit on a quantum computer. We can use the kisskit primitive sampler to run this circuit
many times and gather statistics on the measurement outcomes. If we perfectly teleported Alice's state to Bob every
time, then Bob would measure his cubit to be zero every time, but with environmental noise and imperfections in
the gates, we can expect to see some runs where Bob's cubit ends up being one. But as long as the majority of the
time Bob's cubit is measured to be zero, we can call it a success. Here we have a histogram of the measurement outcomes of
all three cubits. Bob's measurement is shown to be the first slot of each three-bit string. As expected, the four
outcomes that correspond to his bit being zero are much more likely than the other four. So, we have successfully
teleported a quantum state. But look how far we teleported. This is a map of all the
cubits on the quantum processor that we used. And in the experiment, we used just these three cubits.
Alice's cubit was here and Bob's cubit was here. So, they were almost right next to each other. We could have
achieved the same thing by just applying a couple swap gates, which as the name suggests, just swaps the quantum states
of two neighboring cubits. Quantum teleportation is useful for transporting quantum information long distances, and
quantum states have been teleported hundreds of kilome before. For our experiments here, we're limited by the
size of the chip, but we could make the teleportation a little more impressive by teleporting a state between two
distant cubits on our quantum computer. So, let's try that. Here's our new circuit diagram. It looks a bit more
complicated, but nothing has fundamentally changed except that now Alice and Bob create their shared EBIT,
then separate. This series of lines and X's represent swap gates which move
Alice and Bob states from one cubit to another. Alice moves up to cubit 1 and
Bob moves down to cubit 12. Then Alice creates her random state on cubit 0 with
this unitary. Keep in mind that she's making the state after she and Bob have already
separated. So Bob is already far from her.
Then the teleportation protocol continues as before and Bob ends up with Alice's original state after his
conditional operations. We apply the inverse unitary gate and then check that Bob's cubit is
in the state zero. And again we see that the majority of the time Bob's cubit was found to be in the zero
state. So teleportation was successful.
The success rate isn't quite as high as when Alice and Bob were next to each other, though. All of those swap gates
can be expensive and cause the EBIT to degrade a bit. Quantum teleportation might seem like magic, but as we've
seen, all it takes is entanglement, a classical communication channel, and some cleverness. The original 1993
proposal that we've covered in this video formed the foundation for other protocols such as quantum gate
teleportation and is an essential ingredient for quantum computation and communications.
On the experimental front, scientists have continued to push the boundaries of quantum teleportation, even managing to teleport
the quantum state of a photon between a lab on Earth and a satellite 1,400 km
above it. And to teleport quantum states through a noisy classical internet cable. If you want to teleport your own
quantum state, head over to the quantum teleportation module linked in the description below. Thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time.